[Music]  Ravin gates is going to paradise I'm  always looking for love and you know I  got something going on this summer in  Mexico the 25 year old Arkansas native  made the big announcement on Mondays  after the final rose  shortly after viewers saw Nick vile  proposed to vanessa Grimaldi and lead  Raven go just don't know if I'm in love  it's like I know my heart somewhere else  thankfully Raven seems happy and ready  to find love again  I know that if Nick can go to Paradise  and do this experience and fun love that  I can too skál we can't wait to see  Raven living it up in Paradise who from  bachelor nation do you want to see her  date tweet us your thoughts at ET now  you